WHAT'S THE WEIRDEST THING
YOU'VE
EVER DONE IN YOUR HOTEL
ROOM?
WHAT'S THAT SLAPPING SOUND?
SPIDEY'S HANDS STICK
TO EVERYTHING, SO HIS
MASTURBATION GAME HAD TO ADAPT.
CHECK OUT THOSE SPECIAL
DARK CHOCOLATE NIPS.
YOU CHUB IT UP BEFORE WEARING
SPANDEX.
I GET IT.
THE GUY HAS NO PARENTS.
GIVE HIM A BREAK.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE FORGET
SPIDER-MAN IS A TEENAGER
WHO'S STILL DISCOVERING
HIS BODY.
YOU'LL NEVER BELIEVE
WHO HE'S SHARING A ROOM WITH.
HOUSEKEEPING.
JUST KIDDING.
IT'S YOUR ARCH NEMESIS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THE "DAILY BUGLE,"
SO I GOT YOU "USA TODAY,"
AND I MADE YOU A WAFFLE.
YOU BETTER LEAVE A TIP
FOR THE CLEANING LADY.
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE COMIC-CON
CIRCUIT, ROOMS FILL UP QUICK.
ARE YOU TRYING TO SHATTER
THE GLASS CEILING,
OR JUST CRAWL AROUND
ON TOP OF IT?
ARE YOU AFRAID OF SPIDERS?
>> A LITTLE BIT.
>> YOU DON'T LIKE 'EM?
>> SPIDERS ARE CREEPY.
>> AGREED.
NOW, HAVE YOU EVER GOTTEN HURT?
>> NO.
LIKE, JUST BRUISES, SCRATCHES.
>> DO YOU HAVE GOOD BALANCE?
>> NOT REALLY.
>> NO?
>> NO.
>> HOW DOES THAT WORK OUT
FOR YOU?
>> IT'S--YEAH, I DON'T KNOW.
LIKE, REALLY CLUMSY, BUT...
>> HAVE YOU EVER TRIPPED
WHILE YOU WERE UP ON TOP
OF A ROOFTOP?
>> YEAH, I HAVE.
>> YOU HAVE?
>> I WAS KIND OF RUNNING ACROSS
AND THEY HAD, LIKE, THESE WIRES
ON THE TOP, AND I DIDN'T SEE IT,
SO I KIND OF JUST FACE-PLANTED.
>> BUT NOT OFF THE EDGE?
>> NO, NO.
>> NEVER HAD ANY CLOSE CALLS
ON THE EDGE?
>> NOT REALLY, NO.
>> CAN YOU DO A PULL-UP?
>> I CAN'T.
>> YOU CAN'T DO A PULL-UP?
>> NO.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WANNA HEAR
WHEN YOU'RE UP ON TOP OF A--
OF A CRANE,
IS THAT YOU COULDN'T--
IF YOU DID FALL--
DO A SINGLE PULL-UP
TO SAVE YOUR LIFE.
WHO'S FILMING YOU?
>> IT'S USUALLY MY BOYFRIEND.
>> YOU THINK THAT HE'S HOPING
FOR THAT ULTIMATE VIDEO?
>> DUNNO.
>> DO YOU THINK HE'D
KEEP FILMING?
>> UM...
THAT THOUGHT HAS CROSSED
MY MIND.
>> I MEAN, I SURE HOPE SO.
THERE'S NOTHING WORSE THAN WHEN
SOMETHING GOES WRONG
AND THE CAMERA MAN
SHUTS THE CAMERA OFF.
EVEN IF YOU DROP IT,
LET US HEAR THE SOUNDS.
IT SEEMS THE EARTH'S
YELLOW SUN TURNS SUN
INTO A SUPER FREAK.
AFTER A COUPLE OF WEEKS
THE FORTRESS OF SOLITUDE
STARTS TO GET TO YOU.
IS HE FILLING IT WITH AIR
OR SEMEN?
I BET HE ALSO HAS A CHUNK
OF KRYPTONITE SHOVED
UP HIS POOPER.
IT STARTED WITH UGLY WOMEN
BEING ON TELEVISION.
NOW HERE WE ARE
FAT SUPERHEROES.
THANK YOU, OBAMA.
SUPE'S NOT THE ONLY KINKY MEMBER
OF THE JUSTICE LEAGUE.
BATMAN GETS OFF ON BEING
TREATED LIKE A BABY.
HOLY STINK BOMBS!
DOES BATMAN HAVE TO GO POTTY?
>> CLEAN MY BUTT CAVE, ROBIN.
>> UGH, SOMEBODY'S GOT
AN UPSET TUMMY.
>> IT'S WHAT'S IN MY DIAPER
THAT DEFINES ME.
>> MUST BE AN ORPHAN THING.
WELCOME TO LAS VEGAS.
THE ECONOMY IS HURTING EVERYONE.
EVEN BRUCE WAYNE
HAD TO TAKE A JOB
HANDING OUT TITTY BAR COUPONS
ON THE STRIP.
UH-OH, LOOKS LIKE THERE'S SOME
TROUBLE IN SIN CITY.
AND I'M NOT JUST TALKING
ABOUT JEFF DUNHAM'S
UPCOMING APPEARANCE.
WE'RE ABOUT TO WATCH BATMAN
FACE HIS TOUGHEST FOE YET--
A LIQUORED-UP CHOLO.
[laughter]
- JUST SUCK MY [bleep].
- BATMAN JUST TOLD HIM TO SUCK
HIS MOTHER[bleep] [bleep].
THAT'S DEFINITELY
CHRISTIAN BALE.
[laughter]
THAT GUY'S GOT A TEMPER.
RIDDLE ME THIS.
WHERE IS BOY WONDER
WHEN YOU NEED HIM?
PROBABLY AT TAO, MAKING OUT WITH
ONE OF THE HOT MALE BARTENDERS
THAT I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT.
[laughter]
HOLY BITCH SLAP.
YOU SHOULD KNOW BETTER
THAN TO PICK A FIGHT
WITH THE DARK KNIGHT.
THAT'S HOW HEATH LEDGER
DIED.
[audience ohs]
- SOMEBODY BREAK IT UP.
- UH-OH.
[audience ohs]
THE IRONY.
A SPINE INJURY
WAS THE SAME THING
THAT PARALYZED SUPERMAN.
[audience ohs]
THIS IS WHY NO ONE IN THE UFC
FIGHTS WITH A CAPE.
SURE IT LOOKS AMAZING,
BUT IT'S REALLY RESTRICTIVE.
[audience ohs]
SO HARD WHEN YOU REALIZE
YOUR HERO IS ONLY A HUMAN
AND MOST LIKELY HOMELESS.
OH, HE'S WOBBLY.
BUT THAT MIGHT JUST BE
BECAUSE HE'S DRUNK.
WE'RE JUST GLAD
THAT CHRISTOPHER NOLAN
DIDN'T MAKE THIS CLIP
THREE HOURS TOO LONG.
AND FOR THAT,
WE THANK YOU.